many of the old faces are back but a
meaningful number of new ones made it
into lebanon's parliament which now has
a new balance of power
the iranian-backed hezbollah party and
its allies lost their majority but no
other political grouping or party can
claim victory the opposition may be
sizeable but not united
what is a first however in post-civil
war politics are the so-called
reformists who won at least 10 percent
of the seats these are candidates not
affiliated to any of the mainly
sectarian parties
we have to be
as a
king
maker
because we have not
we don't have to be in the polarization
we have to create a bridge
those new voices will stand in the
middle of long-time enemies tensions
have already spilled onto the streets
supporters of rival parties fought on
election day
local observers also documented attacks
on their teams by supporters mostly from
shia groups hezbollah and amal many
observers witnessed so many pressures
especially in the electoral districts of
south and balboa carmel
by some of parties delegates and agents
and even supporters
the shia groups may have preserved the
27 seats allocated to their sect but
observers say they can no longer claim
sole representation
they did everything they can to
intimidate
voters candidates and their
representatives in the constituencies
and at the same time
there's also a an alternative shia vote
so there's a shia vote which went
outside
the box and
to their opponents and that happened for
the first time in spite of their
attempts to keep it contained through
the ballot box there is no doubt change
has begun but the old divide hezbollah
and its allies on one hand and the
christian lebanese forces on the other
hand gone away
lebanon's leaders will need to work
together to agree on a new government
and elect a president in a few months
political deadlock is not unusual in
this fractured country but there is an
urgent need to adopt reforms and laws to
rescue a collapsed economy and a
polarized parliament won't make that
easy
the divide dates back to the civil war
which ended in 1990 after which power
was divided between sects but lebanon's
parliamentary democracy is in reality a
consensual democracy unanimity is needed
for the system to work and peace to be
maintained
michelle duahie is a university
professor and a newly elected member of
parliament from northern lebanon he
joins us from zagata hello there
michelle thanks for being on this
newshour lebanon was hoping for a new
beginning but they've ended up with more
divisions in parliament as a newly
elected member congratulations by the
way how do you plan to provide stability
for lebanon
thanks for having me on the show
obviously i mean this election happened
while lebanon has been
experiencing and going through major
major economic collapse on all sorts of
levels
when i say economic collapse obviously
is linked to political collapse to
security collapse and so on and so forth
public sector destroyed private sector
destroyed everything is not working in
this country and though in these
circumstances i mean the elections
happen
the results of the elections very
quickly before i just
share with you our plans as reforms when
you come into the political scene and
lebanon is that first of all
the turnout
the average turnout was not as high as
we expected and this is a message for us
this is a message for us that lebanese
people are still finding it hard to
trust their politicians even there if
they are newcomers and this is probably
probably linked to the fact that
the political life of in lebanon for the
last three years has been i mean
controlled and manipulated by people by
people who have actually
destroyed
more than ever everything that is linked
and everything that
everything that made lebanon special
in that sense
in that sense we we found it a bit hard
to to try to convince people to go out
there and vote having said that expats
lebanese living abroad did an amazing
job
voting in big numbers for for for the
opposition so this is this is where we
stand now obviously our our i mean our
main goal is the following
to be able to legislate to pass in laws
to stop the bleeding this is this is the
first thing we want to do
second thing the second thing we want to
do is actually
to
to uh to allow lebanese people to have
hope again to have faith in these
newcomers of the political scene this is
very very important it helps this is
positive energy we need to be there we
need to motivate people we need to
engage people we need to remind them
that the practice of politics can be
good that not everything linked to
politics is bad because they've seen bad
practices for the last three years as i
said earlier this is very very important
but obviously the priority stop the
bleeding talk to the ayat we need to be
able to although this is not the job of
the parliament but we need to be
informed about any negotiations
happening between the lebanese
government the imf lebanese government
the eu lebanese government the world
bank and so on and so forth so we have
to be able to tell the lebanese people
what is happening this is very very
important when i say we want to be the
voices this is not a populist rhetoric
this is really a new practice of
politics because that will help us at
some point regain the country we will
literally show the lebanese people
everything that is happening within the
lebanese political system all the
institutions this is very very important
so and we need their backing at some
point and but we need to get there we
need to get their approval and i think
that the only way to do that is to show
them how serious courageous and
people and we are and we have actually a
plan this is this is the only way out
for now michelle that being said how
slowly do you think the decision-making
will be if alliances aren't made and
there's no majority in parliament
this is this is i mean we don't want to
go into deadlocks again because
deadlocks have been been sort of
part of the political life because it's
a consolation of democracy as you
mentioned
in your report uh we need we need to
break that break that deadlock we need
to be able to legislate people voted for
us they expect us to be mature and when
i say mature
on the parliamentary at the
parliamentarian level it means we need
to pass in laws legislate and this means
we need to talk with other groups inside
parliament we need to get signatures
this is part of the parliamentary life
this is i mean no one has a much total
majority in terms of one block having
said that when it comes to sovereignty
issues i think our group uh the
newcomers i'm gonna call them that for
now i'm sure we're gonna find the name
at some point uh we're gonna
we're gonna be very very clear that this
country is not going to be able to
breathe again
unless
the only the only i mean the army and
the uh and the
official security services have control
and full monopoly over the weapons it
won't it won't
be able or not be able to
do it i mean to
come out of this uh of this mess without
without i mean
fixing that so it's a two-track it's a
two-track thing the economic collapse we
need to be there with the right laws
with with with really establishing what
we call the separation of power i mean
judiciary has to be independent
legislative body has to do its job and
there is the executive body
and the third job and lebanon part of
the problem is this practice it means
those three functions are we have a
fusion so we have members of parliament
who are ministers that they appoint
judges and this is why the system is not
breaking we gotta be there so that the
practice of democracy is healthy
well you certainly have a big job ahead
we wish you all the best michelle dewi
an elected member of parliament thank
you for your time
thank you for having me